last Sunday of course we were reeling
from those evil murders in El Paso and
Dayton not much to be positive about I
said but we need to try and tonight
that's what I want to do to move from
hate to hope to be positive that's what
the president did this week he set out
the widest and most aggressive plans to
fight the evil of white supremacy this
country has ever seen
putting the full resources of the
federal government behind a new effort
to root out this corrosive mutation of
racism online and in our communities
he's taken the lead on guns pushing
forward understanding the nation's
demand for action but also its respect
for the Second Amendment we'll get to
that issue in a moment on white
supremacy on guns on the substance in
terms of policy action leading us from
hate to hope that's actually what
President Trump was doing last week what
were the Democrats doing
they chose hate hate directed towards
the president and his supporters they
are so intoxicated by their own
self-righteousness and sense of moral
superiority that I don't think they
understand how their rhetoric is heard
when they attack president Trump half of
America hears it as an attack on them
the Democrats called the president a
white supremacist when he had literally
just announced an all-out assault on
white supremacy they called him a racist
when he has published an immigration
plan that literally calls for over a
million new immigrants every year as
long as they come here legally and on
merit
ben Carson nailed it a racist would not
be doing the things that the prisoners
doing with you know with the second
chance with the Opportunity Zones with
the things that I just mentioned there's
so many things a racist wouldn't be
doing that forget about it in its
projection ISM you know I don't know why
people do it
I guess it's political but if we can
stop being politicians and start being
representatives of the people and
actually deal with the problems that
they have I
we can make a lot of progress as a
nation I so agree with that
look when I hear the Democrats smear
Trump supporters the way they have this
week everything in me wants to hit back
but I won't because I don't want to
raise the temperature I want to lower it
and unlike the Democrats who talk about
bringing people together but spend their
time driving the nation apart I want to
practice what I preach remember from
hate to hope here's how you can be
positive in the face of this reckless
and offensive provocation from most but
not all of the Democrat presidential
candidates don't respond in kind don't
escalate don't tweet don't pour fuel on
the fire instead make sure you get the
ultimate revenge winning don't hate vote
and here's what we're gonna do tonight
yes we're going to talk about guns the
president is leading that debate and
we'll discuss it in a moment but we're
going to go wider and deeper here's how
I see it
president Trump inherited a broken
economy and he got it working for those
who've been left behind we now have a
booming economy but what we're seeing
now is that we have a broken society and
that gives the president his mission for
the second term mend our broken society
family breakdown failing schools
inadequate skills these problems have
been with us and getting worse for
decades but we can turn it around
president Trump can turn it around with
the same energy he applied to our broken
economy so we will bring the hope
tonight with positive and practical
ideas and let's hope for our politics
too I was at the Iowa State Fair on
Friday and it wasn't just fun but
inspiring I talked to Governor Reynolds
of Iowa who's doing an incredible job
and I talked to three Democratic
presidential candidates who aren't
joining in the chorus of hate candidates
who I don't agree with but whose
campaigns are positive we'll show you
some of those conversations tonight but
first the latest on the gun debate
President Trump has made it clear he
wants to see something happen and he is
absolutely right
I think a lot of really meaningful
things on background checks will take
place including red flags including a
lot of other very very important items I
think in the end Wayne and the NRA will
either be there or baby will be a little
bit more neutral and that would be okay
too my advice is the President on this
trust your gut
you know the American people are crying
out for change they don't want machine
guns on the streets and in the hands of
people who could carry out such
unspeakable evil think of those
beautiful children their lives cut short
their parents destroyed if you're the
president that finally breaks the logjam
on guns whilst protecting the Second
Amendment you won't just guarantee
re-election you'll go down as a historic
change maker president up there with
Lincoln and Reagan so ignore the
Heartless do-nothing crowd there was a
sick repulsive do-nothing editorial in
the National Review this week bastion of
the never trumpets ignore them the never
Trump establishment ID logs were wrong
on immigration wrong on trade and
they're wrong on guns too I said last
week that your supporters hate this
white supremacy filth as much as
everyone else and if you denounced it
there'd be cheering you on it's the same
with guns trust your instincts your
supporters will be right behind you